[Applause]
good night everybody
so that was something
betterment and Oz no sane person would
have approved of that no insane person
would have either even Gary Busey would
have said this feels a little off
just goes to show you that for the Dems
it's only about filling a seat not doing
the job if they thought a stale muffin
could win they'd run it and after
watching fetterman last night maybe they
should have at least his stale muffin
wouldn't crumble that much in front of
the cameras but they're so power mad
they let a clearly unwell man fall apart
on live TV
which is really the job of Joe Biden's
staff
stay in your lane fetterman
it was so painful to watch the host
should have been given a safe word
but fetterman's desperation was nowhere
near the desperation of the media who
before the debate made excuses for the
poor guy they circled the wagons even
when there was nothing to circle around
they primed the Press with prepare for
awkward pauses and some verbal flubs
what sounds like a great slogan for
Kamala Harris 2024.
but I guess watching Biden for the past
two years that wasn't even preparation
enough for this
but the rationale from the media was
pre-chewed and spoon fed to them as if
they're the ones who had a stroke and
then afterwards the excuses flowed like
Snapple through Joe Biden's pants John
fetterman clearly has some speech
struggles because
his authenticity was there I think under
the circumstances John Federman having
had a stroke actually did very well the
Republican party is running a bunch of
ads about showing fetterman yeah uh
stumbling on things because of the
stroke what kind of a doctor is behind
that aren't you supposed to do no harm
he had some really really strong
comebacks betterman lost the battle last
night but may have won the war
wait a second who actually had the
stroke here
I think it's contagious then there's the
debate for the New York Governor between
Republican Challenger Lee zeldon and
Democrat Kathy hokel if only her
approval were as high as her eyebrows
this is a Woman by the way who was never
voted in by the people of New York she
just happened to be in the right place
at the right time like when Steve
ducey's limo once hit a young homeless
man named Brian kilmead
zeldin talked about what was on voters
Minds which is not being murdered or at
least let's get murdered by new
criminals you know just to keep things
fresh
and this is how Nancy Pelosi's face
tester replied there is a crime
emergency this governor who still to
this moment what are we halfway through
the debate she still hasn't talked about
locking up anyone committing any crimes
okay anyone who commits a crime under
our laws especially with the change they
made to bail has consequences I don't
know why that's so important she doesn't
know why she acts like zeldon had just
made a disparaging remark about the
color of her shoes or why she likes
orange juice with pulp
is disgusting sorry
but it says it all about the modern
Democrat they prefer fake victims over
real ones remember as crime raged across
her State she made it a law to refer to
people in real estate with gender
neutral pronouns such as real estate
sales people or salespersons I could see
the criminal on the stand during his
trial you know then I stabbed her 22
times before throwing her off a bridge
you know the judge goes sir I'm not
going to tell you again you must
respectfully refer to the person you
butchered as they or I'll insist on bail
in your case
I'm sure the Realtors will be pleased
when New Yorkers use the right pronoun
as they scream for the love of God sell
our home so we can move to Florida
and months before that she announces
that all SUNY college campuses would
enforce chosen names and pronouns to
ensure that transgender non-binary and
non-conforming identities experience a
diverse inclusive environment for the
lgbtqia LMNOP qrst
sorry I'm getting tired of a community
that demands more letters than an
episode of Sesame Street you know what
why not just pass a law saying all
heterosexuals must transition by 2025.
I feel like we're almost there I mean
have you seen Harry Styles
but I understand the governor's concerns
imagine the horror of getting
misgendered on the coroner's report
after you've been murdered
so she asks her Challenger I don't see
why putting criminals Behind Bars is so
important to you well because Kathy it's
not important to you that's the problem
the governor abandoned citizens concerns
for the attention-seeking woke garbage
that are staff handpicks off Twitter
and while it makes you feel like a good
person inside it makes you look like a
good person on social media you're just
a vapid virtue signaling vomit bag
and now she can't offer real help just
fake help otherwise she'd make crime
fighting number one and save the
questions about IDs for people who are
trying to vote
and now they claim any attempt at Law
and Order is systemic racism answering
only to activists instead of crime
ravaged citizens they pat themselves on
their spineless backs over pronouns nice
work Z why thank you they
I'm sorry you dumb hack you just gotta
go people are getting killed on subways
they're raped on our streets and you say
why is that so important to you I think
we found your new pronouns it's dumb and
ass
[Applause]
timing in Rob Schneider
he knows more about Clinton dirt than
anyone who isn't buried in it president
of the government accountability
Institute Peter Schweitzer
there we go
for Halloween she's going as my arch
nemesis a theme park measuring stick
let's see his contributor captain
and when he needs his shoes to shine he
goes to the car wash my mouth decided to
get in every ways World Television
Champion Pirates
rob it was an embarrassment of
embarrassments yeah but you know what
though you just if you're fetterman you
just gotta shake it off go home tonight
kiss the kids good morning
and just get right back at it yesterday
[Laughter]
no if you're forcing that guy out there
you are forcing that you're the cruel
person yeah it is an apology you know
apologizing for him is you know for
fetterman's performance and where he's
at it's just it's like apologizing for a
drunk driver you know like you know yes
okay yes he was inebriated but no one's
giving credit for how well he drove
before he killed your whole family yeah
you know it's true he could have started
off with a joke maybe maybe the good
night thing was supposed to be a joke
and we just didn't maybe it got screwed
up he should have followed it with fire
bad
then by the way
that joke would have worked before the
stroke
yeah yeah I mean that is
that's a family tree I mean it literally
is a tree and Peter um okay there were
two there were two debates pick one
which what struck you about them I mean
you got a political mind what what did
you see what alarmed you what surprised
you I think the fetterman one was
shocking a lot of ways I mean look I
kind of get the naked ambition of a guy
like Federman and his wife he wants to
be in the Senate that kind of makes
sense to me it's it's the reporters it's
it's the how the media is trying to
cover for this it reminds me of the old
uh but you know Parable you're a member
of the the the emperor with no clothes
you know the fool is the Emperor but the
real fool are the people who are
applauding at the wonderful outfit that
he's supposedly wearing when he's
actually Stark naked so I really think
the media is the problem here and
they've made a choice Greg they are
choosing to basically applaud for the
emperor that has no clothes even though
it's destroying their credibility
because they are so committed to their
cause now you have me thinking of
fetterman naked
what's weird is that's the second time
today
what's amazing
they already cast a million votes before
this debate yeah that's insane it's
remarkable his team released a state a
statement saying that he did remarkably
well and that they were thrilled and
everyone is focusing on that's
gaslighting how can they Gaslight
everyone like that and I'm just thinking
what if they're not yeah what if they
are thrilled because they're used to
seeing it be much worse well that's like
that's all that could possibly mean
maybe they're telling the truth and
they're like phew that could have gone
terribly you're right and you know what
you're right you're right and get this
talk about dishonest he had a stroke
before the primary yeah but with Conor
lamb and they did they keep that hidden
or they I mean it was like there's so
much weird stuff going on is relevant to
the job because in this country one of
the most important Powers we have as
Citizens is to be able to you know
criticize and question the people in
power over us if you can't answer those
questions or like any questions then you
being in power takes power away that is
owed to us as Citizens that is a very
good point
one theory is that they just want to get
him in so then the governor can just
appoint somebody to replace him so they
get the seat and then they just put
somebody who isn't a stroke victim which
in in Democrat world it's going to be
hard
why would you replace him
why he just changed the vote buttons the
pretty colors don't
press the m m one
you know it's I'd like to I get it he's
he's it was much for me like watching uh
a fighter that you respect right and he
goes out to fight and he gets old that
night and he looks horrible but for some
reason he just won't go down right and
Doc OS to his credit never threw a
knockout blow yeah he's lucky he wasn't
up there against somebody else whose
name starts with Trump yeah because he
would have crucified him but he didn't
do it thinking but here's the thing the
real like a question is if that was my
family member and you and I we talked
about it I said if it was a boxing match
I would have thrown in the towel if I
was this manager I would have got fired
I would have walked out there and I
would have stopped it you know because
they're not if you're not concerned with
his
performance because you're just going to
vote the tent because they don't they'll
tell them how to vote so it doesn't
matter where is his wife when the
primary happened she could have stepped
up and said I'll run for my husband
anyone could have said anything but it
doesn't matter and no one's going to
stop him yeah he went up there and he
actually they actually said he did a
good job considering he had a stroke
it's like Yeah The Athlete did a good
job considering he had a heart attack
and passed out on the he didn't finish
the race but considering a heart attack
he did pretty damn good and by the way
the one thing they're not talking about
he's at risk for another stroke you know
but no I was watching us and I I thought
Oz had like put it took his foot off the
break right and it said but it was still
like watching Leah Thomas Swim laughs
I think doctor I think she's a dude as a
woman swimming against girls yeah okay
explain that joke in the five too I'm so
I don't know what the hell is wrong with
orange juice and Pulp it's the
healthiest version of it that is so
disgusting I like Paul Everyone likes
Paul Gutfeld it adds a little something
like he drank five alive when you were
kids no we just drink orange juice and
don't use orange juice to color our
vodka by the way that's yeah nobody here
room
I mean he's not lying but what about
nobody cares about Kathy hokel who won
who won Peter uh zeldon won okay zeldon
one here here's the thing the the
problem that the political left has in
America today is they want to solve all
these problems that are abstract like
climate change and you can't measure
climate change it's the it's the things
that are nearby like crime like Safe
Streets that they don't want to talk
about and I think the American people
are fed up with that and I think they're
you're seeing that and you're going to
see some surprises on Election Day and I
think the governor's race is going to be
one of them I hope so because this place
is getting unlivable all right
foreign
's Got Drugs crime and foul odors plus
Services stolen by freeloading
if you'll be in the New York area and
would like free tickets to see Gutfeld
go to foxnews.com Gutfeld and click on
the link to join our studio audience
[Music]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else